you've got three kids you're saying um
they've got fantastic names olympia
lightning bolt thunderbolt and st leo
bolt so they've all they've all i would
imagine got the bolt sprinting gene
who's the quickest
uh well right now olympia my daughter is
definitely showing um
um that she wants to run she runs
everywhere she's always on her toes she
walks on her toes like a sprinter so
that's something that i look forward to
but my boys are just one so i'm keeping
an eye on them
do you ever get i've spoken to racing
drivers jensen button told me every time
he goes out in a car on a on a normal
road there's always some bloke in a pool
she wants to try it on with him at a
traffic light and zoom off
to you is the fastest man to ever live
do you find that everywhere you go
there's always somebody who wants to
try and take you down and what do you do
about it all the time it's all the time
um
for the older people i just laugh but if
kids if they really want to try i'll
i'll i'll race with them sometimes if i
have time on my hands
and sometimes i'll let them win if
there's a smaller kid but if bigger kids
i won't let them win
they've got to learn the hard way you
say that's how you learn how to win um
jamaica's going through
younger kids
sorry god
for younger kids it's it's it's it's
it's much more fun to let them win you
know i mean because they're really fans
and they look up to you but all the kids
understand that
it's not always going to be easy to win
you know i mean so i have to let them
know you have to earn this you have to
earn you have to earn away then because
you say all the kids will brag well i
never let any of my kids beat me at
anything uh the problem is that three of
them now have got old enough where they
beat me at everything that's the problem
but i think that's the winning mentality
i gave you gotta enjoy it
yeah you gotta enjoy it while it lasts
you know what i mean i just i definitely
think i'll be that dad also this is
johnny depp he's come out on tick tock
he's just joined tick tock apparently uh
literally today and he's made his first
address on tick-tock and in it he
basically thanks his fans
and amber heard people so this is johnny
depp's statement it's a nice statement
thanking his fans and so on what's more
interesting is amber heard's response
immediately
she's come up from a spokesperson and
said as johnny depp says he's moving
forward what he says in his in his
little uh comment there women's rights
are moving backwards the verdict's
message to victims of domestic violence
is be afraid to stand up and speak out
so amber heard still playing the
downtrodden victim even though she lost
almost all of that case what do you make
of this have women's rights been served
by anybody in this case well absolutely
and i think amber heard arguing the
women's rights have been taken backwards
actually it's been done by her because
of all her false allegations she's
completely delusional clearly because
she's still pivoting herself as this
victim as you know the the face of
violence against women when that's not
the case at all what is incredible to me
is
there are still people in her camp that
are saying actually no she's a victim
and she when no one is speaking on
the johnny depp side of things and the
kind of come on i think i think she is a
victim and i think it's a victory it's
entirely appropriate for him to thank
his fans because the pressure of
celebrity culture the organization the
way the trial was handled uh was
actually what resulted in what i think
most people would regard in this country
as a perverse verdict oh absolutely
absolutely i do absolutely i think it is
clear
that
his star power and his male part if i
can put it that way
she is no angel i certainly would accept
that but i think it's absolutely clear
that she did come under pressure and i
think what she said the new york times
which didn't specify him was perfectly
that
[Music]
that he had been guilty of spousal abuse
by one judge this was not i'm sorry
isn't it fascinating though we've now
had two court cases with these two one
johnny depp lost one he won almost an
entirety and even now people are really
split about this but you see this is
this is the argument which her defense
barrister put out that
if you go into any
domestic abuse situation
and you reduce it to he said she said
she always loses and that's exactly
what's happening i actually don't think
it should have been on television i
don't think you should televise domestic
violence cases either criminal or civil
yeah i think that's it turns it into it
monica lewinsky said it turns into kind
of
courtroom porn and i think that is a
problem you had a great quote donald j i
wanted to replay to you you said there
was very little left on your bucket list
i've seen everything i've been
everywhere i've done it all i love that
well it's the truth and uh and one thing
i'll say is that uh you know i've done
things right and i've done things wrong
but i uh but it's all down on me i don't
blame anybody else we all make mistakes
in life but uh
i don't say i've done it all either i
did it if i did it right it's because i
did it right if i did it wrong it's
because i did it wrong
and um
and one thing i would say is that
um i like to know things you know and i
like to learn about things and one thing
i want to tell you is i followed your
career
and i loved your tv show when you took
over for larry king oh thank you um
i loved your tv show i still remember
many interviews that you did you were a
very very good interviewer and i always
made a point of watching it and i still
know about all the trouble you cause on
morning television with
your wonderful opinions which i most of
the time agree with completely
so it makes me very happy don
this man he wrote this
anthem to my life says that makes me
happy thank you like performing sweet
caroline at the uh platinum jubilee i've
done it quite bad
the other day i'm just obviously
comparing you to the great man because
i'm sure you like the comparison but um
he was saying the other day that only he
and the queen they've got one thing in
common they've had the same haircut for
60 years
[Laughter]
um yeah not not quite 50 years for me
but yeah
are you a roster event well what do you
think well of course you are you must
talk about of course who's not i love
rod he's one of my favorite people in
the world